I see you word Smiths which is good
because the word I'm talking about in
this video is recognition
recog it's a noun it means the act of
acknowledging being aware of or noticing
something follow me over to the atmology
Zone trademark where I'm going to break
this word down this word comes from
Latin re means back again or against as
in review cognos means to know to be
familiar with and IO N is a noun forming
suffix it's what makes this word into a
noun so what we're looking at here is a
word that means the act of knowing
something again right so this is the
noun form of knowing something again you
recognize a person when you've met them
before you recognize a song because
you've already heard it so let's come up
with uh some words that use these word
Parts re cogno that onon ending if you
want I'll give you 10 seconds to come up
with some words to knock some together
okay here we
go here are some that I came up with
Incognito which means disguised right in
Incognito means literally not knowable
if I'm going in Nito maybe I'm wearing a
fake nose a fake mustache right
reconnaissance this word comes from
French it basically means spying it's a
military term you're surveying you're
you're getting to know a territory
before you decide how or whether to
commit troops there same atmology as
recognized but it took a different
language path to get to English and the
verb to ignore to choose to not know
about something to not pay attention to
it same negating prefix as Incognito
right the in or the I part here means
not and the nor the GN o re part means
knowing so not knowing ignore so you
might ignore the spy who is Incognito
performing reconnaissance all right
let's use recognition in some sentences
even at a distance Sherman recognized
The Familiar three-step gate of his old
friend pizot right he could tell he
could identify it from a distance you
can also use recognition to mean that
someone is being appreciated for
something that they've done in
recognition of her service to the city's
Garden Club Christina got a ceremonial
key to the city so here it is not that
someone is literally saying hey is that
Christina I know her it's more like the
city is acknowledging and appreciating
her work it's the effort that she's put
in that they're officially noticing by
giving her a giant unwieldy novelty key
you can hold the giant novelty key to
knowledge wordsmiths if you hold fast to
this
truth you can learn
anything daveid out